rarement avait-on vu un mécanisme de
manipulation de l'opinion ou si
sophistiqué la population visée le plus
gros bassin d'électeurs au monde l'inde
le moyen utilisé tech forgues un
logiciel hyper intrusif liée à une
application secrète le cerveau derrière
cette opération nul autre que le parti
au pouvoir le bjp du premier ministre
narendra modi c'est le média en ligne
doit y baser en aide car révélé ce
scandale dont on commence à peine à
mesurer l'ampleur
jeff cette histoire là pour moi est
ahurissante tu t'es plonger là dedans à
fait intéressé au travail journalistique
aussi qui a amené à tout ça mais on
remonte à la source cela commence à
commencer on est au début de 2020 donc
juste avant le début de la pandémie il
ya un an ford alerte sur twitter qui
affirme que le parti au pouvoir le bjp
ont mis au point une application qui
permet de carrément truquer les réseaux
sociaux à des fins politiques la
pression se faisait un ancien employé du
parti qui travaillaient avec
d'applications là pour affecter
l'opinion publique arabe des réseaux
sociaux donc là le médian indépendante
the wire médecins indépendants et 9e
journée sedan kite s'épancher là tu as
passé vrai moi
écrit sur cette application la valider
ce que le lanceur d alerte affirmé le
constat qui en est sorti c'est que mes
en effet il y avait anguille sous roche
et cette application leur qui se nomme
tech forgues existait vraiment et avec
du tour de capacités pour être capable
d'outils des réseaux sociaux pour
affecter l'opinion publique donc
vraiment de rentrer dans la mécanique
même des plateformes numériques comme
twitter par exemple pour orienter le
discours politique est orienté aussi les
perceptions la politique comment ça
marche tech fox pas simple c'est quelque
chose que personnellement j'ai jamais vu
dans le fond c'est une application clé
en main pour faire des manigances
politiques affecte pas juste twitter
mais facebook ou 6 et what's app c'est
en application où tout est là pour
manipuler des élections dans le ton les
employés du parti ont des objectifs à
remplir chaque jour par exemple phare
oui twitté un certain mot clic dix mille
fois lorsqu'ils réussissent leur
objectif ils sont rémunés donc sa traque
les actions des employés pour atteindre
certains objectifs politiques
l'application elle-même ya tout là
dedans ça permet de créer avec un seul
bouton créer des faux contre ça permet
de cibler certains mots clics faut faire
100 membres dans les tendances de
twitter par exemple pour que plus de
gens les voient ça permet de cibler des
sujets de l'opposition aussi pour pour
modifier la perception dans la
population de ces enjeux là mais ça va
plus loin ça permet par exemple
d'automatiquement cibler des
journalistes les journalistes féminines
ça permet d'étudier certaines personnes
selon la densité
la couleur de leur peau leur orientation
politique à des fins d'harcèlement à des
fins d'harcèlement entre autres mais
aussi pour envoyer des messages sublime
sa fin mais aussi de prendre contrôle de
comptes ou whatsapp qui sont inactifs
pour envoyer des messages aux ennemis de
ces personnes là donc on sait que en un
an whatsapp c'est une des plateformes
sociales les plus utilisés dans son
message à ton ami so what the daily star
thé club était plus porté à le croire
parce que ça vient de ton ami mais en
fait ça a écrit complètement pied raté
ça permet aussi carrément de modifier
des vrais articles de vrais journaux
dont on comprend un vrai article on
l'envoie quelqu'un mais la personne
quand il clique sur le lien il ya des
mots qui sont changés dans l'arctique
pour complètement changé le sens dans la
personne ces défis elle va regarder la
source il voit bien c'est bien le
journal que je connaisse une source
médiatique fiable donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'extrêmement systématique
extrêmement bien que mise au point et
qui permet à ce qu'on suspecte l'une
armée d'activistes l'air d'être capable
de complètement modifié les discours sur
les réseaux sociaux à l'aide d'une
application qui complètement centre et
lesté par un jeff c'est très
sophistiquée et puis on se pose la
question qu'est ce qui arrive si ça
tombe dans les mains d'autres régimes un
peu plus autoritaire est ce que
commencent à se compare en fait avec
d'autres manigances du genre par des
pouvoirs en place dans le monde mais
sont plus comparé soit par exemple ce
qu'est la justice est faite aux états
unis avec l'élection présidentielle de
2016 bon c'était beaucoup moins
sophistiquée que cela d'une part d'une
autre parle on parle d'un parti au
pouvoir qui touriste sur sa propre
population donc une différence à faire
de ce côté là le fait que ça soit
rémunéré qu'on en fait 16 mois comme un
jeu vidéo pour
inciter des gens à prendre contrôle du
discours politique sur des réseaux
sociaux c'est quelque chose que moi j'ai
jamais vu c'est quelque chose
d'inquiétant parce qu'on sait qu'il ya
quand même l'appât du gain
aussi le fait que ce soit aussi facile
donc on a pas besoin d'avoir énormément
de l'habilité par exemple savoir comment
créer des faux contre vous savoir
comment manipuler les réseaux sociaux
c'est tout là c'est avec dans une
application pour faire simplement
cliquer sur quelques boutons pas besoin
de d'avoir énormément de connaissances
sur le fonctionnement des réseaux
sociaux pour être capable de faire
opérer cette machine donc ça c'est quand
même inquiétant
ça reste à voir à quel point par exemple
les mots clics sur les réseaux sociaux
les forces nouvelles ça affecte vraiment
les élections qui a très peu de
recherches là dessus on sait que des
plateformes comme twitter par exemple la
part de la population n'est pas un sur
twitter donc à quel point est-ce que ça
peut affecter l'opinion publique ça
reste à voir mais une chose est certaine
les plus concrètes confusion dans disco
politique le plus que ça devient
difficile de savoir qu'est ce qui est
vrai c'est là qu'on devient plus
susceptibles d'embarquer dans la
désinformation parce qu'on sait pas où
donner la tête donc on va se référer à
des gens qu'on connaît et les mécaniques
de cette application de ressemble
vraiment utiliser sa com com comme
technique d'approché que ce soit qui ait
quand même inquiétant c'est ce qui en
fait son succès potentiel d'où les
inquiétudes que suscitent
les astres étaient presque alignés pour
que le scandale tech fog émergent en
inde un parti au pouvoir omniprésent le
savoir faire technologique immense et un
électorat très malléable surtout dans
les régions rurales de ce gigantesque
pays un pays que connaît très bien le
journaliste français sébastien farsi
correspondant à new delhi
sébastien farsi bonjour bonjour à tous
alors votre éclairage va être essentiel
pour comprendre le contexte dans lequel
se déploie tout ce système qui
franchement me laisse pas mal abasourdi
avec une telle chose puisse se faire me
semble absolument incroyable mais dites
nous comment commencer quelles
répercussions a eu toute cette affaire
on est d'abord et avant tout dans ce
pays où vous vous trouvez depuis
maintenant 10 ans et bien la
répercussion malheureusement où enfin on
peut dire à la pas été à la hauteur peut
être des révélations d'autres médias on
en parlait pendant quelques jours puis
après c'est un peu retombée il ya eu
quelques répercussions parlement
l'opposition s'est saisie de ce sujet a
demandé des comptes au gouvernement
mais le gouvernement donc dirigé par le
bjp qui ce parti donc qui aurait utilisé
cette application est bien démenti bien
sûr complètement et selon eux mêmes une
phrase qui est quasiment comique en
disant nous avons cherché cette
application sur les apple stores et les
autres et nous l'avons pas trouvé et ça
c'est ça s'est arrêté là c'est à dire
que ce démenti est quasiment ironique
c'est pas en cherchant sur un peu le
sport qu'on trouve cette application
c'est pas une application grand public
donc c'est une réponse qui en soi n'est
pas une réponse qui montre bien que
c'est un peu pour se moquer peut-être de
l'opposition l'opposition qui demandent
les journalistes et les descentes de
journalistes demandent aussi une enquête
de la cour suprême la cour suprême qui
est souvent dernièrement le dernier
recours en fait que qu'on trouve pour le
respect des droits de la liberté de
grands parce que c'est le recours
judiciaire multi où est le dernier
recours face au pouvoir de plus en plus
écrasant du bjp une machine politique
redoutable en 1/2 parlons-en de cet
acteur est au coeur de cette affaire
qu'est ce qu'on doit savoir pour
comprendre comment était et pourquoi été
mise en place ce système cette
application présumément
mais pourquoi on peut imaginer on peut
imaginer qu avoir accès à tous ces
numéros de téléphone qu'on puisse le
what's up en effet un outil sied très
bien whatsapp et une usine vraiment de
communication très efficace et très
utilisé en inde et les gens aujourd'hui
ils reçoivent leur premier téléphone
dans les campagnes parce que l'internet
est très peu chers internautes mobiles
et très peu cher d'eau qui reçoivent
lors le message soit ça qui sont pas
encore éduquer à la désinformation donc
il produit prennent ça comme de la
vérité donc c'est très efficace la
machine électorale du bjp il faut savoir
qu'en effet c'est le parti le clou
riches les immensément riche en inde
c'est un ancien parti le seul parti le
vrai parti moderne on sait qu'on utilise
ces technologies
il utilise toutes les données privées ce
soit les factures d'électricité que ce
soit les numéros de téléphone c'est un
parti qui est connu pour utiliser les
données privées pour identifier en inde
ya toutes ces castres les gens il faut
identifier chaque circonscription et
tout cet ensemble de données permettent
et bien de cibler ses électeurs et
technologues en tant que tel est
justement un outil qui permet de cibler
et d'attaqué ouais un outil très très
intrusif comme vous le décrivez mai mais
qui a dû être développés qui a dû est
pensé et conçu par kick quelques aces
pouvoir industriels ou de la haute
technologie derrière sa caisse qu'on
doit savoir à ce sujet
et bien c'est là où on voit qu'en effet
l'inde est pionnière on le sait dans le
même des nouvelles technologies relais
aujourd'hui on sait la capacité la
silicon valley indienne à bengalore a
développé le monde la technologie cloud
sur le site qui vient ici et il ya une
énorme multinationale qui s'appelle le
système qui est alors lorsque la société
a démenti mener une enquête qui est très
bien fourni active les journalistes avec
qui j'ai parlé qui ont mené l enquête
qui est donc d'un système qui a
développé cette plateforme donc c'est
une géant informatique qui est non
seulement présente en inde mais en
europe aux etats-unis et au canada
donc c'est une société qui bien sûr vend
des produits clés en main de performance
technologique d'amélioration de data de
big data donc ce sont ces zennaro
multinationale indienne mais qui parfois
semblent rsa soit sur le sueur sur
l'éthique alors il faut savoir que
l'inde n'a pas une vraie loi de
protection des données privées 1 ce qui
permet aussi ces abus et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement n'a jamais vraiment poussé
à parce que ce soit ce sera le cap mais
ce qui arrive aujourd'hui en inde
pourrait arriver en europe pourrait
arriver au canada aussi si on ne fait
pas attention alors que reste-t-il de
l'espoir qu'une éventuelle enquête
puisse arriver à son terme et nous
donner toutes les informations
nécessaires pour comprendre ce qui s'est
produit est ce qu est ce qu on peut
espérer 101 dans le contexte actuel
l'espoir peut-être fondante et fort mais
aussi doux de la cour suprême vient la
cour suprême qui est encore une fois
semble être le dernier rempart
de l'opposition pour contrer cette
machine électorale qui est riche plus
puissante un espoir qu'on partage en se
croisant les doigts au nom de la
démocratie et de la consolidation de la
démocratie en inde sébastien farsi merci
beaucoup beaucoup pour cet entretien
merci